there is no substitute for victory we must
then the culture of losing that has infected
the Republican party in recent years he's in
the Florida governor Ron DeSantis officially
kicking off his bid for the White House and he
did it on Twitter the tired dogmas of the past
are inadequate for a vibrant future we must look
forward not backwards this evening's rollout on
Twitter did become with a technical issue and a
crash the event was delayed with those technical
difficulties in fact this is what people heard
when they logged on at 6 PM Eastern which was the
advertised start of the announcement let's see so
here we are yeah like so um just to simplify that
well it kept getting cut off by the time
it started this antis made a joke that he
broke the internet Biden's campaign wow
made light of desantis's tech troubles
tweeting this link works and then the
link went to a Biden fundraising pays